[Music]
fantastical interview through Disney's
Tangled and frozen take place in the
same universe did you know that
Sebastien makes a cameo in Aladdin here
are 22 did we Easter eggs and fan
berries that just might connect their
animated self together let's start with
wreckit-ralph residentsleeper on Hiro's
computer and appears in several
billboards in San fransokyo and big hero
6 you can find a frozen Easter egg a
wanted poster of the villain from frozen
Prince Hans is found at the police
station of fransokyo many fans noticed a
connection between frozen entangles at
Elsa's coronation Rapunzel and Flynn
Rider are easily spotted in the crowd
tangled makes several references to
older Princess films the spinning wheel
and her Tower looks very similar to the
one from Sleeping Beauty also several
princess storybooks appear in the
library at the castle a darker fan
Theory also connects tangled and frozen
with two other Disney classics
The Little Mermaid and Tarzan some fans
believe that Elsa and honest parents
were on their way to Rapunzel and Flynn
wedding when they were shipwrecked so
the shipwreck could possibly be around
Denmark the location of the Little
Mermaid which is between Norway where
frozen takes place and Germany where the
tale of Rapunzel originated there for
sunken ships in the Little Mermaid that
Ariel visits is actually Elsa and Anna's
parents ship
The Little Mermaid sure is a connection
with another Disney Princess film the
king and do from Cinderella are present
at Prince Erik and Vanessa's wedding
characters from The Little Mermaid make
appearances in other Disney films in The
Princess and the Frog King Triton is
clearly displayed on a parade float The
Princess and the Frog also has a
reference to Aladdin the magic carpet
appears in the opening sequence of the
film Aladdin connects back to the Little
Mermaid because Sebastian the crab has a
quick cameo Aladdin references to
when the Sultan is playing with his toy
we can clearly see the beads from duty
disease in his stack of animals the pile
of animals looks pretty familiar just
like the one in the Lion King during I
just can't wait to became a character
from The Lion King appears in perkily
scar makes an appearance as the flame
Nemean lion a fan theory connects
Hercules back to Aladdin when young
Hercules sings I can go the distance he
sees a shooting star but is it really a
shooting star some believe that it's
actually the magic carpet zipping past
screen the magic carpet appears again in
The Hunchback of Notre Dom during the
song out there if we look closer at the
screen grabs we also see Belle from
Beauty and the Beast the new live-action
community nodded to this during Belle's
visit to Paris with the beef other
characters from reading the beef appear
in Tarzan mrs. Potts and chips are
clearly seen in the scene where the
gorillas trashed the camp it's Jane a
descendent of El Jardin might also be
related to other differences
remember the shipwreck from frozen some
fans believe that Anna and Elsa's
parents survived the shipwreck and were
stranded on the island with Anna and
Elsa's younger brother baby Tarzan
Tarzan has another Easter eggs
professor quarters drops the stuffed
animal of little brother from Mulan when
he's hanging upside down
Mulan appears in lilo and Stitch in a
poster in nanny's room
finally stitch from Lilo & Stitch
appears as a stuffed animal and Treasure
Planet we know there are even more
Easter eggs in Disney films share your
favorites and let us know how you say
the films are connected in the comments
below
[Music]